did you get to go on the remotes because
Conan did a few remotes while he was
there too I was on the dog remote yeah
that was hilarious that was yeah really
funny yeah Conan's had really bad luck
with dogs these were the guard dog yeah
well one of the military dogs yeah and
they trained them on the base and to
attack people to attack and so they put
him in all of that crazy it it almost
looks like a Hazmat except it's like
three like a Stay Puft Marshmallow yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then they they
threw him out there as bait for the dog
that was training and it took him down
yeah well yeah they were like okay on
the count of three run as fast as you
can well I need you to come over here
otherwise my dog
I love America
and it's really hard to run in that
outfit right I don't know why terrorists
wear it by the way yeah that's a little
bit of a exactly a little bit of a
handicap they like it to be even Steven
and I I remember he was scared I mean it
was scary
yeah this will be funny right yes coding
just you do it I trusted you we missed
the shot
one more time yeah Conan says in it you
know this is probably the dumbest thing
I've done in my career was it hard to
convince him to put the suit on I mean
and was Jeff there Jeff Ross was it and
he he was a was he paying attention Jeff
Ross was in the same costume and he
wasn't even use
he was 40 feet that's what he called it
I wouldn't do it yeah the golfing on the
guitar bass is premium
it's always in the sand well Conan got
attacked by a guard dog when we shot I
know for the Mexico show and he had no
that was not a purpose yes oh Jesus and
it was dogs no a jerk to attack dogs
know when that's a talk show host yeah
[Music]
um was it a German Shepherd who doesn't
know it was a Belgian Malinois
they were really scary yeah the scare
even scarier than German Shepherds yeah
they are yeah that's a police dog and
and it was you know it was trained to
chase after him but it wasn't supposed
to bite him and then it did oh my gosh
and it punctured the skin yeah yeah but
it was a great take it
was funny to see the Grimace
it was just a scratch from a drone shot
you weren't even nearby yeah
I think he's writhing in pain but it's
hard to tell let's do it again and we'll
have the Drone closer no I thought about
that because it is so often that you're
like oh yeah now put on the suit and
you're gonna go do the demonstration
it'll be funny and it's right but you
know these dogs are trained this is a
real
Real Deal attack dog and that they're
they're not performers no and everyone
handling that dog was very No Nonsense
it was all just like we're here to kill
yes to take down and go for the throat
well yeah and I was watching I mean it
was fun he's used to puppies right like
I was watching the puppy conans which I
always do during video yeah but it was
so oh my God I forgot so many can you
explain what it is the Puppy Bowl exists
for people who don't want to watch the
Super yeah
if you don't like my show you can watch
puppy Conan instead which makes no sense
oh my God it was just uh it was
hilarious just the dog problems the
Chris Christie dog took a dump on the
Christmas Day
and we ran over
he really did his research and the
little uh Justin Bieber dog just looks
so scared I mean the dogs were so the
puppies were so well cast but it just
reminded me of all those problems too if
we can't have breeds intermingling so
some of the dogs were outside the sad
and some were inside and didn't Andre
end up with one of those puppies yeah
moose is one of them yeah they're the
writers and we did it every year for
like yeah the other puppies were all put
down at Conan's request which I thought
was unnecessary
that's not true we're just joking
he adopted a puppy we had a dog
character called the evil puppy oh I
remember the evil puppy
the curtain would open it was just
like a red chair like a Red Devil
with Carmina Burana playing and you know
to to Satan
and I was like I'm gonna adopt that dog
that's how most people end up adopting
that sure that's right